-Welcome back, everybody!
We're about to play
a fun new game,
but first,
I'm gonna need some help.
His new album,
"Twelve Carat Toothache,"
is out June 3rd.
And he's the musical guest
this weekend
on "Saturday Night Live."
Please welcome Post Malone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
I missed you, dude.
-I missed you, too, Jimmy.
-I missed you, bud.
Come on.
That's my dude right there.
That's Post Malone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's my man.
Come on, bud.
How you doing, bud?
-Thanks for being here.
Post, we're gonna play a game
called "Point, Turn, Sip."
-You got it.
-Here we go.
-♪ Point, Turn, Sip ♪
♪ Point, Turn, and Sip ♪
-All right.
Basically, it's a game
people play on TikTok.
It's a drinking game
where I either swipe left,
right, up, or down,
and you move your head left,
right, up, or down.
If we match, you drink.
If we don't, I drink.
Okay, we're gonna sip beers.
And since
you're a brand ambassador,
whoever takes more sips
each round
gets to do a shot of Jager.
-What?!
-Yeah, a little Jager
right there.
Okay, here we go.
Let's start this.
I'm gonna go first. Okay?
-Okay.
-Let's get into position
right here.
-Okay.
-All right, Roots,
whenever you're ready.
-And I'm trying to match
where you're going.
-You're trying to not match.
-Not match?
-Not match.
-Okay.
-Ready?
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-I've already --
♪♪
-No!
You're good at this game, Jimmy.
[ Buzzer ]
-Fantastic, all right.
2-2, all right.
-That's pretty good.
-That's not bad.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Tie on that one.
That's not -- you see what's up?
-Yes, sir.
-Well, I should do a shot.
I forgot, I have to do this.
-Wait -- oh, wait.
We both get to do it.
-Oh, we tied.
-Hey, all right.
-Good to see you, bud.
-Yeah, we did --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Whoo-whoo!
Ru-ruff! Ruff! Ruff!
All right, here we go bud.
-You got it, Jimmy.
-Next round,
it's up to you, bud.
All right, here we go.
You do it.
♪♪
-Oh!
[ Laughs ]
-Aah!
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-There you go.
-You drink.
Oh, I'm sorry.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter ]
-I was asking you to drink.
-I was dancing. I was --
-Yeah, into the groove
right there.
Do I get the lead there?
Yeah, I think -- I won that one.
So you take the shot, bud.
-Oh, I forgot to sip, too.
-Yeah, you forgot the sip
and the shot.
There you go.
That's for you, bud.
-You're good at this game.
-Thank you.
I'm pretty much a pro, yeah.
[ Air horn blares ]
You know what
that air horn means?
-Of course.
-Party, first of all.
[ Laughter ]
There's a party somewhere.
It also means it's time
for the bonus round.
-Of course.
-Yeah.
All right, for this last round,
we're gonna up the stakes,
and we're gonna do alternate
pointing and head turning
as fast as we can.
-All right.
-I feel like I'm gonna do
a lot of drinking here.
All right.
First of all, I want to say
I love you.
[ Laughter ]
You're my favorite dude.
-Jimmy, I love you, too, man!
-I love you, dude!
[ Laughter ]
All right, here we go.
I'll point first.
Roots, whenever you're ready.
♪♪
-Ooh.
[ Cheers ]
Oh, I got it!
-Wait.
What am I doing?
-Aah! Okay.
[ Buzzer ]
-I won, yes!
-What the hell --
-That's exactly
the way to do it!
How do I do it like that?
-What's going on here?
-That is for you, bud.
-Jimmy was so quick to push this
right up in front of me.
He goes,
"Don't forget about this, man."
-I'll do one, I'll do one.
I know -- I'll do one with you.
Just 'cause
it's good to see you.
-Cheers, guys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Post Malone right there.
I love a good Jagermeister.
Stick around with more Post
after the break.
Stick around.
Come on back, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]